hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
gonna explain a 1998 american superhero
action movie called blade
the movie begins with a pregnant woman
sent into a hospital's emergency room in
1967.
the paramedics said she was attacked by
an unknown animal
she received medical treatments but did
not make it fortunately her baby was
born and survived
years later two young people a man and a
woman are having a night out they go to
a secret rave club and while enjoying
the music the man notices blood spilling
from the fire sprinklers
he then realizes that the partygoers are
vampires who need to satisfy their
bloodthirst however the party is
disrupted by the appearance of blade a
vampire hunter he comes prepared and
attacks any vampire who dares to fight
him while the rest scramble away he
recognizes one of his attackers named
quinn and sets him on fire before he
leaves
the paramedics and firefighters arrive
and take quinn's heavily damaged body
at the hospital karen a hematologist and
her co-worker dr curtis are examining
quinn's dead body karen finds an
abnormality in his blood cells
while checking the corpse quinn suddenly
comes back alive and instantly bites
them both before escaping blade arrives
at the scene originally aiming to
capture quinn but he remembers his dying
mother while seeing karen so he decides
to rescue her they escape the cops then
he brings her to his crib where his
co-worker whistler injects her with
garlic essence
she has been bitten so it will only be a
matter of time before she is turned into
a vampire meanwhile the vampires are
having a council meeting the elder
vampires are raising concern over the
recent attack by blade on a rave club
owned by deacon frost a human turned
vampire
they believe vampires can survive by
blending in with humans making back
alley treaties and staying out of
trouble while frost believes they are
destined to be a far superior species to
humans and intends to wage a war between
vampires and humans the other vampires
look down upon him because he is not a
pureblood vampire but frost insists on
his plan
karen wakes up eavesdropping on blade
and whistler's conversations about her
she observes whistler injecting blade
with an increased dose of a serum which
gives blade a strong reaction that he
must be restrained then they prepare to
move
realizing that karen is awake they
explained to her that they are in the
middle of a secret war between humans
and vampires which sometimes
accidentally involves innocent people
like her she has been marked by the bite
and some vampires will eventually come
for her so they suggest she get out of
town if she wants to stay safe whistler
also reminds her to buy a gun and watch
for signs of turning into a vampire such
as intolerance to sunlight exposure and
excessive thirst
on the other hand frost seems busy
deciphering ancient vampire texts that
he trespasses into a sacred archives
room
blade drives karen to her apartment when
taking the elevator she notices people
near her bearing similar tattoos on
their necks
afraid that they are after her she
quickly walks to her apartment door then
immediately gets in
however she leaves the door open causing
a seemingly casual police officer
krieger claiming to be on his routine
check to check on her while they
converse karen notices something is off
then krieger attempts to attack her
she defends herself using the garlic
essence to which krieger is confused
because he is not a vampire blade
appears and defeats krieger instantly
explaining to karen that krieger is a
familiar human loyal to the vampires
karen realizes blade sets her as bait to
lure the vampires krieger escapes then
blade attempts to chase after him
karen decides to stay with blade
realizing he can keep her safe they
discover a nearby vampire safe house and
make their way in this time they
encounter krieger again
he shows them a secret entrance to an
archives room before reporting back to
frost who is throwing a party frost
deems him useless and attacks him then
orders quinn and his men to catch blade
there blade and karen meet pearl the
keeper of the archives and torture him
using uv lights to make him explain a
prophecy
it says that the spirits of the twelve
will wake the blood god of lamagra and
that blade plays an important part in
fulfilling the prophecy while looking
around the archive room blade notices
someone has been following them which
turns out to be newly healed quinn and
his henchmen
he and karen barely escape to the
underground subway tunnels defeating
some of the vampires in the process
after making sure they are safe blade
injects himself with his serum that
suppresses his bloodthirst
karen deduces that he is a vampire too
whistler explains that he took care of
blade whose mother died at birth after
getting attacked by a vampire the attack
gave blade a vampire super strength and
bloodthirst but because he is also human
he does not inherit a vampire's weakness
to garlic and silver
he also does not age slowly like typical
vampires
frost and his men execute dragonetti one
of the pureblood vampire elders by
exposing him to sunrise
they take out his fangs and present them
to the vampire council meeting forcing
other elders to obey them blade gives
whistler a piece of the ancient text
from the archives room to help him
deduce frost's plan
meanwhile karen borrows some equipment
from the hospital to conduct her blood
research aiming to find a cure for blade
she introduces them to edta a compound
usually used for treating blood clots
she tries mixing it with a vampire blood
sample and it explodes which can be used
as a great weapon against them proud of
her findings she takes a sample of
blade's blood and continues working to
find a cure
she notices whistler keeps coughing to
which blade replies that he has cancer
whistler on the other hand notices
karen's bite marks and tells her that
she only has at least two days before
fully transforming into a vampire
blade goes outside and meets with frost
at the park he invites blade to join him
convincing him that he would not be
received by humankind because of his
mixed origins
blade refuses which causes frost to be
angry
turns out he heads to whistler and
karen's hideout karen just discovers a
cure for herself but it does not give
the same effect on blade's blood sample
they are surprised by frost's ambush
frost tortures whistler and abducts
karen then leaves
when blade arrives he finds whistler
severely injured whistler explains that
blade's blood is the key piece that
frost needs to complete his ritual of
summoning la magra and start a vampire
apocalypse he forbids blade to chase
after frost again but blade refuses
then realizing his wounds are too
damaged whistler asks for blade's gun so
he can commit suicide before turning
into a vampire then he prepares for an
ambush on frost's base and packs karen
said to serums as one of his weapons
frost brings karen to his lavish
penthouse and explains to her that he
believes vampires are the superior race
on the planet
blade intrudes frost's base and defeats
several of his men
he learns that karen's serums work as
the vampires he injects them with
eventually explode when entering frost's
bedroom he learns that his mother is
still alive
she looks young and undamaged even
embraces her new identity as a vampire
frost appears and hurts him from behind
exclaiming that he was the vampire who
bit his mother years ago the vampire
that blade has been looking for all his
life he throws blade into a dungeon with
karen when the ritual is about to begin
at the temple of eternal night they are
separated blade is taken by his mother
to a cage where his blood will be
drained to supply the ritual while karen
is taken to a cell
there she discovers that her past
co-worker curtis survived the vampire
attack but he is now transformed into a
zombie-like creature she outsmarts him
and escapes from the cell then quickly
heads to fine blade frost has gathered
the pure blood vampire elders as his 12
sacrifices for the lamagra ritual
blade's blood spills through the wall
then trickles into each of the
sacrifice's foreheads then the
sacrifice's lives are drained away while
frost starts to gain the full power of
the blood god
karen finds blade and frees him who is
in a very weak condition
she deduces he will die by his lack of
blood and suggests he bites her to
consume some of her blood and regain his
strength
he does it and his super strength is
restored
then he encounters his mother and
defeats her he continues defeating
frost's henchmen one by one until only
frost remains challenging him to a duel
blade learns that frost cannot be
defeated by weapons as he can easily
regenerate his body and sustain any
damage
he notices his edta serums being stuck
in the temple walls and aims to loosen
them
frost thinks blade wants the serum to
enhance his strength but he attacks
frost with all those syringes
the overdose of etta causes frost's body
to inflate and eventually explode blade
picks karen up and they escape from the
temple
karen explains that she can continue
working to find a cure for blade but
blade is concerned that his war against
vampires is not yet over
he proposes she work on a better serum
instead that he can use against evil
vampires
sometime later he intercepts a brief
vampire attack in moscow russia
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching